do you know what they need to do they
need a drill drill into my gums into the
bone yes take a screw out implants I'm
not doing all that yeah but then and
they said that I have weak bones uh oh
what yeah when I went to the I swear to
God when the dentist goes right now your
bones are so weak you know why why is he
roasting you dipping no this is way
before I was dipping this is before I've
had weak bones Dr tunzi said this yeah
yeah this is a real you guys makeup
makeup
Dr cartoonsy it was another place that I
went to toonsy didn't say nothing like
30 of us have the same dentist
and he could do it then yeah he could do
it it's just they got a drill I'm fine
I've learned to survive but if your
teeth are just you watch homeless people
do it
and I sit there and watch them I go to
[__] the mission and I watch them eat
and I go right you shred it with your
fingers
I'm watching these yeah yeah yeah can I
can I tell you guys it's kind of scary
when I've seen him eat steak like he
sucks on the flavor and then he swallows
it whole yeah that's and it works but
you're not eating steak your stomach
breaks it down what true your stomach
your teeth at this point
you're a Next Level human oh God steak
night
I don't talk about my teeth anymore yeah
you and your brother please like he has
no teeth too huh yeah what is going on
with you guys we're toothless
you're the Disney Animation hey hey
you're gonna hurt his feelings
he doesn't have any that's the problem
that's a good you could word play man I
think you know I I rap and I'm a dad
yeah it's like both I know you're better
than dumbfounded
you right
no I love John but um
you know how do you have guests on your
podcast not not the
um not ours together no yeah why just
because it's just our thing our special
thing okay but you should come on mine
my I have a separate podcast I'd love to
do it yeah yeah please that'd be great
you have your own genius yes genius how
many episodes in
373. you have guests on yours not much I
have the same reoccurring people so come
on I'll come on yours you have guests on
yours yeah all the time
are we good
what's wrong are we good no we're good
it's just I feel like you're gonna say
something and I'm just getting ready
yeah your whole body I'm like I'm
sweating right now I'm gonna I did set
you up because I was like how many
episodes I know Bobby eel okay
it's because I've always it's fine no I
love Margaret you love everybody else no
you're my favorite
you are literally my favorite yeah
you walked so I could run oh oh and you
showed me the light when I was in the
forest keep going keep going and you
yeah were the deer in the force that I
shot that gave me nutrition to live yeah
wow and you are the fatty and now a
[__] beauty is that even and you yeah
should get teeth because so you could
choose that's negative no it's not no
it's not we were always a positive thing
now you always go negative no no you
didn't let me finish yeah yeah please
fix your teeth no he wants you to enjoy
food I enjoy it trust me I enjoy it you
guys he doesn't want to talk about his
teeth anymore I love I've challenged
myself it's a challenge you know what
yeah yeah I respect you even more now
which is crazy to be fair he had a
really bad like the itchiest athlete's
foot for like years and years
the reason that he would never get it
fixed because we obviously a lot of
things he could put on it he's like I
like scratching it like it's a hobby
it's a hobby but I've changed that I
don't scratch it anymore my feet are
[__] oh yeah cause we broke up and
you needed to find regular girls oh I'm
absent what can I just say a thing about
the boss we have this kid Macomb you
know McCone uh no I don't so you know
Brendan dermer oh yes so it's his buddy
and he's a 23 year old kid and we're on
a tour bus have you been on tour boss
you've been on tour bus right I've been
on I haven't toured on a tour bus but
yeah this is my first time really on my
own tour bus you know I've been in
business for a long time what's the
matter
I've been doing it for years no that's
what that nod was no wasn't I
you're shaming me it's fine I'm just
starting to do it you keep attacking him
and now he's scared
he's been attacking me just to jump no I
haven't certainly here
so there's this kid that we have we
don't know him right but we love them
now but um and he's on the bus he's our
videographer 23 years old but he has
night terrors oh he does
5 30 in the morning this is not kidding
you no
any morning it's like you know some
people have [__] roosters yeah to
wake them up we have this guy oh God
right and you know we tell he goes oh no
I had a great child no you were brutally
something she something happened to you
brutally right right night terrors I
think night terrors is more of like a
sleep disorder though but why is he
always screaming don't touch me on all
that because when you're in your like
dream state like you're just not you
know you're in sleep you're in physical
paralysis but your mind is still active
so it's not like you can physically but
every morning it's always then if that
was the case it would be sometimes it
would be like I love this Cloud it's so
fluffy right but it's never it's always
aggressive no I get like night episodes
you know this yeah and that's because I
was like diddled as like a child and it
happened a lot in like the middle of the
night yeah so I I wake up and I get the
hard episodes and all of that but
sometimes I think some sleep disorders
are just sleep disorders it's more of
like a brain issue do you guys like my
haircut it's so cute not being real I
love it did Johnny do it
yeah I love them I can't see what the uh
show on the back
I like the mullet your hair is so it's
really full full yeah I debate he's
doing the mullet you guys have such nice
hair so do you no it's very thin like
it's receiving